opportunity village is throwing a spooky  shindig for the halloween season it's  the magical forest being transformed in  the haunted jungle for halloween  families children all ages all invited  for the rides the carnival games the  trick-or-treat stations opportunity  village says it has an incredible  opening weekend last week  very exciting lots of energy here it was  just so great to see everybody come back  for the community here to come celebrate  the season with us i mean the parking  lot was full and it was just so much fun  yeah remember there was no halloween  last year because of the pandemic if you  want to check it out yourself  it is open this weekend and then october  22nd through the 31st you can get your  tickets now at halloween with the v  halloween dot com